get out of my dorm get out
you do not pick another step towards you
she has a weapon see how they teach the
children to treat their guests
got them
also can we acknowledge how nice of a
dorm this is look how tall this is
immediately be like these are wakandans
also there's too many windows I mean the
the light that you're getting in that
room is just incredible each of them has
like you could jump out of any of those
windows I'm just saying like the door
might lived in in college you could not
jump out the window
[Laughter]
oh it's funny I love her
yo ain't no ass on her head her head is
perfect okay
he's so fully moisturized how dare they
I think
I think we're a commenting like hey Eric
didn't mention the ashy comment I'm like
you think I'm going to tell them
24 7 you guys be respectful welcome back
to new rock stars black panther wakanda
forever deprived us of a long speculated
post-credits scene that would have
revealed Dr Doom in the MCU rumor has it
but was a trace of Victor Von Doom
accidentally left behind in this film in
the form of Riri Williams MIT Professor
answers
this is inside Marvel it's new
Rockstar's weekly Marvel reaction show
and despite the dozen other what kind of
river videos you can see on the channel
in the past week this is the first time
Mt and Jessica and I have had a chance
to react to this movie together and
we're gonna be unscripted it's gonna be
a spoiler filter of lifted conversation
we're gonna get into all the
nitty-gritty of what we loved uh what
we're still having questions about from
wakanda Forever uh and yes we will be
spoiling everything in this movie so if
you haven't seen the movie yet pause
this video go watch the movie come back
to us I'm Eric boss I'm here with
Jessica Clemens and Mt Hello friends
what's going on it's exciting to see
this movie being such a hit that it is
uh I was I was really worried going into
it you know I didn't know it's it's a
definitely a risk to make a Marvel
superhero movie without like a focal
hero who is like gonna be on screen
driving the platform but really they
just made a story about a community
about a group of people about two
warring kingdoms and it works like on
like it seems like so far at least an
opening week the audiences are here for
it like they need this movie oh yeah
yeah like this movie was truly unlike
any other movie in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because like it was like this
weird meta commentary that like
obviously we're dealing with the passing
of Chadwick Boseman and like it's but
like they did it with so much like tact
and like would so effectively that like
the beginning of the movie like with the
silence like at the beginning and end of
the movie with the silence like so
powerful like Ryan coogler truly
um made a product that that was um was
truly respectful to his friend Chadwick
and like I need to see this like two or
three more times because I've only seen
it once and like I need I need that
experience again in my life because like
it was truly something special I I think
the the really smart strategic move with
the plot is just using the character
sure I mean they had to kind of leave
behind some of the things we loved about
shuri in the past films and really
evolve her into an instrument of grief
in this film but I didn't you know as we
watched it I didn't realize how much
that we really needed that not just for
morning Chadwick Boseman but uh mourning
anyone in our lives like this movie is
like a fascinating exploration of what
is the best way to grieve how do we
listen to our better angels and what are
those better angels are they something
within us or are they something from
Beyond that we have to listen to are
they invisible hands that guide our
steps every day of Our Lives uh or is it
our own inner demons and our own inner
angels that are warring against each
other we just have to listen to a
certain side of that
um which is fascinating I you know I
think Leticia Rick did a great job I
really love how this movie
um basically did what Civil War did with
um with Chadwick and and Zemo and just
like we continue that with the story of
Vengeance and how Vengeance can really
destroy everything and can get people
killed because like if shuri did not
follow Chadwick's I'm sorry t'challa's
example of of mercy and being like a
kind person showing compassion
um even at the face of the person that
killed one of their parents like another
parent killer for the the for this
family
um but God mercy and like I think that
that was so powerful and so like so
amazing just to celebrate the the person
that t'challa was in the MCU this is
like this person that cared I like mean
Sherry
kill him no
because there is a storyline briefly and
I think I can't remember what comic book
this was ages ago that I was looking
into it about sure very being a black
panther and being not necessarily a good
or bad black children but just like yeah
she was ruthless she was fueled with
anger just like she was in this movie
and I like that because it's like like
Wanda Vision it gives us grief but it
gives us grief in like an actual real
time it felt more which is interesting
because one division was a series that
feels like it could actually do it for a
long time but in this movie they did it
really well conveying what grief can
make people feel and instead of going
through like the seven stages of grief
she really just went through she jumped
the gun on like three of them and went
straight to anger and it's like and I
like and I like that because it's a
scientist of someone that thinks
logically all the time finally not
sounding so logic with their sense of
anger and letting it control them and
being like no you guys don't understand
what you're talking about I know what
I'm feeling because I have like done
every math every equation to figure it
out and it's like yeah I love that
explore your grief dive into it let
anger fuel you for a little bit I also
root for Emperor Palpatine so I'm not
really someone
let the hate flow through
do it well just now you got me wondering
what the other two mystery stages agreed
for I thought there were only five
stages
I think one's smell and taste right yes
that's exactly what it is what is plasma
when is gas you know it's it's
what it is sure he's the scientist not
me sorry keep going well uh Justin
really excited I know you have a video
coming out soon on the channel about
what's next for Riri Williams and
ironheart uh in her series and that's
that's the angle I want to talk about uh
starting off in this episode of inside
Marvel specifically one line that Riri
mentions this mystery professor and uh
there's a lot of uh speculation it's
just one quick line it's really easy to
miss
um but now we're all wondering could
this mystery Professor be Doctor Doom
it's kind of like that one division
aerospace engineer all over again
because we know there's some reports of
like uh was Dr Doom going to be in this
movie was he not uh and at first I just
said oh that was just like the rumor
mill run rampant but now I'm looking at
this movie again and thinking there is
something that was missing from this
movie and you could see the residual
Trace elements left over
um I'm just gonna go through what we see
here so Riri becomes a scapegoat of this
movie really she's targeted by telecon
for building a vibranium detective
everybody tells shuri that while she did
build that machine she did not build it
for the CIA it was not a plot that she
was helping the CIA like attack wakanda
or other kingdoms out there this is just
a class project it was for True academic
purposes here's the exchange sure he
says I'm here about the vibranium
detection he built for the CIA Riri says
I didn't build no detector for this for
no CIA I made that for my Metallurgy
class sure he's like a school project
everyone goes yeah my professor said I'd
never be able to do it to be on gifted
and black though right now you know I'd
love that delivery from Dominic she's so
good in this movie uh but Metallurgy by
the way it's an area of study and
Engineering that study is the physical
and chemical behavior of metallic
materials that you're using for building
stuff it's kind of class where a
professor might build oh I don't know a
sick metallic mask to match a screenshot
no I am just going I'm having a little
fun with that this is why we really
cannot let go of this professor because
the whole reason Riri gets drawn into
the conflict of this movie is that her
invention without her knowing is given
to the CIA someone took it from her
class and gave it to the government
without her consent of doing that this
is some [ __ ] Professor who doubted
her abilities and then stole her
technology to give to freaking Val to
get a leg up on the wakandans and this
is super Shady this professor completely
doomed his student and it never gets
addressed again in the movie and I think
it's just too big of a deal to get
ignored there was like she's hinting at
this mystery of like someone in her
orbit who took her idea from her claimed
it as his own and then gave it to the
government to use for the various
purposes and now that we're on this side
of the wakanda forever I went back to
look at those leaks from last summer and
we know a version of this movie existed
in July because that's when uh you know
in the official black panther podcast
Tony easy coats confirmed that he saw a
full cut of the movie some point over
the summer we think it was sometime
during July before d23 uh and this is
the month that you could trace back
those early unconfirmed reports to so I
think someone else is in that screening
room and started putting stuff on Reddit
and 4chan and other places these reports
claim that this movie would end with a
second post credit scene that would
reveal Dr Doom the description was that
Lake Bell's character Dr Graham she's
the CIA ocean scientist who led the
diving team that we saw in the movie in
this reported claim she was going to
report back to some mystery benefactor
who gave her that vibranium detector and
that would be Dr Doom now of course this
scene was not in the movie Nate Moore
and Ryan coogler insisted Doom was never
part of the plan but I don't know if we
can believe them because when you go
back to look at those leaks beat for
beat they were right about pretty much
everything else that ended up being in
the Final Cut of the movies sometimes it
was in different orders but like all the
big stuff that happens all the temple
moments it all happens as it does in the
in the theatrical cut and you can
definitely step back and see something
is missing here because Lake Bell she
might not be a huge name but she is big
enough that casting her just to play the
CIA scientist who the more kills in the
First Act I would say a bit of a waste
of her Talent at least a waste of money
for to pay someone that big to play such
a small role it's kind of like how the
cast Richard ship as this U.S Secretary
of State shift does come back at least
one scene later in the film you can
imagine this guy probably showing up at
secret Invasion and armor Wars and
things like that uh so I think there is
this Missing Link of Shari's [ __ ] MIT
Metallurgy Professor who has some shady
connection with the CIA it's a mystery
set up in the film never paid off in
fact my conspiracy brain has taken me
places right now like I think those
reports of Sasha Baron Cohen playing
mebisto and ironheart might just be red
herrings like a cover story a massive
truth that he's actually playing Victor
Von Doom on the show which makes a bit
more sense because it is a show about
the intersection of Science and magic
and what character and Marvel uh lore is
always described as the intersection
science Victor Von Doom
um I really hope that's special very
Cohen is playing Doom just so though you
can see my mom my mom
my mom
or he talks to uh Agatha Harkness and
says like my eyes every other witch also
my wife my wife so I think wakanda
forever was always going to end with
introducing Tucson and AKA uh to
Charlotte Junior but I think that was
really originally just going to be this
movie's ending not a mid credit scene
like notice how the mid credit scene
picks up directly where the final scene
leaves off with shuri on the beach I
think that was originally all part of
one scene there wasn't going to be a
break the movie it was going to be the
movie's original ending sequence because
just like you want to include like it
seems like something he would just
include as the grace note at the end of
the film as kind of the answer to
Shari's prayers it doesn't feel like
something tagged on to the end and like
an additional twist it feels like part
of shuri's natural uh story her Arc in
the movie before you cut to any credits
um so I think that was originally going
to be the original ending of the movie
but then after this Doom twist leaked
over the summer Disney's like and it
decided to remove the Doom scene and
then trimmed off that tassant part uh
and then move that to the mid credits
and I think it was probably ultimately
to right move to do this because
thematically I did not need Dr Doom to
be in this movie I think the movie works
way better as is and I think if anything
there was just too much MCU stuff in
this movie we'll talk about that later
in this episode I I I can't really fall
thematically it's story structure wise
the way they did it the way they did and
again this is just my conspiracy brain
reaching here but I want to ask you do
you think I'm reaching and if not what
do you think the story is with riri's
mystery MIT Professor I would like it to
be Doctor Doom just because I also and
this might just be me because I know
Doom because we talk about him so much
but I like jumping the gun and making
his first introduction not an origin
story just starting them already as bad
he's already bad he's already stealing
ideas from his from his little children
um I like the idea of that I would love
it but I also do ultimately do agree
with you that was like one thing when I
did the Black Panther Recon forever
review was I was like well I think some
of you guys won't like this because
there's a lot of Marvel stuff in it and
then some of you guys will like like it
because it has a lot of marble stuff in
it when I was like this feels more like
a farewell package to not only uh
Chadwick Boseman but to the phase four
of the MCU so I was like this is kind of
weird but sorry going back to
um Dr Doom I would love that it has to
be true I think Nate Moore is just Nate
Moore and he has to say that like their
original plan wasn't to have it they
can't be like Whoa We actually thought
about it like no they can't say that so
it would make sense that it was
something that was shown in a room they
said no we're scrapping everything and
now they have to stay planted on their
new idea their new answer to why Doom's
not here we believe that there were like
talks of Doom potentially making an
appearance or like pointing towards Doom
I think that like considering that
Fantastic Four is kind of a ways away
um but then again mutants are away um
the X-Men movies a ways away and we're
getting mutants so um I think that it
might be a little bit too early
um for Doctor Doom um just yet just like
I mean I don't know their plan but like
I think that if Doctor Doom is going to
be introduced it feels like ironheart
would probably be the um the the series
if that he would be introduced in
considering that we do know that um the
hood is going to be involved in that
story um and the hood is a very mystical
being the hood is like the Nexus between
like magic and you know guns and like
it's like magic and
um man-made materials that's sort of
what Dr Doom is he's like he's the next
between Magic and and Real Worlds like
science and stuff so like I can see like
um the Hood maybe teaming up a doom or
like learning or wanting to learn more
about magic from Doom but like I don't
think that black panther will kind of
forever was going to be like a doom
introduction it just it always felt like
to me that Marvel Studios wanted to
dishonor Chadwick and like try to figure
out um what's next with the Black
Panther Legacy and let's focus on that
and then um just introduce Doom in some
other title but I don't know who knows
yeah I agree with that because it's like
we also have the first black panther
where it was felt like a very black
panther film and then the very last
scene is just Bucky coming out of a tent
so I think it was like gonna be to that
degree where it was like here's a one
second thing here's a one second
offshoot uh but also now that I'm
thinking about it I get what you're
saying about the red herring for
ironheart but it just seems like this is
a stretch I'm about to say Doom kind of
feels like a lower version the hood
seems like a lower version of Doom in
that regard of like magic and Tech
because it's like he uses a gun a pistol
yes but the magic is in his boots in his
cape so it's like it's not really like
he's demonic it's the appendages that he
stole from a demon so I'm like I'm like
they maybe they were always gonna plan
on having to be Mephisto and not Doom in
iron heart but like yeah I think that's
still very likely and you know you don't
have to adopt every uh little part of
what I said wholesale
um bring up a couple different you know
anytime like this is like my how my
theory brain works I try to find three
nodes of of like information to hang it
on right and there has to be like three
points really to form like a line that
goes into one clear Vector
um and for me those three nodes are like
this these Uncle unproven unverified
claims that there was gonna be a doom
post credit scene this mystery of Riri
Williams Professor that's definitely
something that would that would you
don't put that in a movie like it just
seems so weird it'd be one thing if she
just mentioned a professor who doubted
her abilities but then that professor in
order to kick off the conflict to the
movie off screen gave it to the CIA it
was Mark Zuckerberg back at it again
whatever it shows up stealing people's
ideas she didn't go to MIT
um do you think
do you think they're maybe holding that
they put it in there it's kind of like
the same situation with you know like
the earthquake under the water that they
talked about it's like do you think he
put it in there as like a little
sprinkle so if they do want to approach
the whole like how many students are at
MIT because we know that like Ned and MJ
are still there do you think they're
like maybe they can make it Doom
eventually and doom teaches MJ and Ned
or something I don't know I feel like
yeah I think that's why I'm partially
excited for this to introduce Victor Von
Doom in the world of Academia because
that is how we meet Victor I Believe In
A Fantastic Four or no maybe that's not
how we meet him but like that is his
backstory that's how he met Reed
Richards and Ben Graham he was one of
their roommates he's like I don't want
to stay in this guy's room so they get
rotated out and Ben Grimm like sabotages
his experiment like this this is like a
college drama it's like social network
stuff that's their backstory and that's
how I want the Fantastic Four to be
introduced I want to see them as like
grad students or teachers at a
university and the fact that we have
MJ we have flash we have Ned and now we
have Riri
um and potentially Peter Parker is going
to come visit at MIT this is the place
to like unfold that story I think it
really makes sense to introduce Victor
Von do and we know this is this isn't
new to Marvel like you know Doc Ock was
a college professor who's like a
colleague of Ned con or not uh Kurt
Connors I should say
um and the Sam Remy Spiderman movies
um but like I guess I guess my thing is
if we compare it to the earthquakes
under the ocean you could looking back
just argue the the context and the
subtext of that scene is Natasha this is
not a big deal this is under the water
move on let go of it like the characters
are literally saying this isn't a big
deal let go of it and it's all just like
the fans who are like oh that could mean
something in this case it was like
presented as something like hmm hold on
I have like a couple follow-up questions
there like it was me the way that scene
was written is it was like meant to like
set up like something that was going to
pay off later that we're gonna meet this
professor oh only because like I think
we can all agree ReRe Williams they kind
of had to invent these excuses to force
her into the story to tie her into the
story I think Dominique Thorne does a
great job but it is you can see the the
gears turning and it's a very synthetic
uh implant of this character in the
movie so they had to like find a way to
do that and they clearly did a lot of
work to justify why she needs to be in
the middle of this conflict and the fact
that they needed for to preserve Riri as
an innocent character to counterbalance
that as a screenwriter you have to
invent uh some kind of justification for
why this happened and as it stands right
now we still do not know why her
invention was thrust in the middle of
this it was a it was a choice it's not
like the government has track of every
single student project that's happening
at MIT and well Tech you know we also
have to consider that you know a Val is
a factor in this movie and we do know
that the leader is out there he's going
to be a a
um a factor in in New World Order this
could very well be like manipulate like
the leader trying to get that thing that
he needs to find vibranium it's like all
right we get it from this this um this
girl and then we just we just take it
and then we just use it for our stuff
and so like I I have a feeling
that the leader could be behind the
discovery of riri's machine sure at this
random like School Affair the science
fair thing
um it just feels like a Metallurgy class
yeah I don't know
um yeah I think the leader absolutely
could be tied in with this too I mean
there's all kinds of foes out there
there's uh Hydra might still be
operational in some way the Scrolls
could be involved in some way Kingpin
could be funding some of these efforts
it's kingpins the teacher absolutely
this is how you make an omelette egg
white it's just really good at ball
energy for no reason yeah if you want to
use the bathroom you need to take a hall
pass
I think you meant may I use the bathroom
hey I used the bathroom
God he's always out of breath he always
sounds like he's out of breath he always
out of Brett like he's just finished
running I love him he's got all this
weight to Lug around
that's true that's the adrenaline
puppling in his system he's like I'm
gonna use a car door on you in like two
minutes well uh I don't think uh we can
definitively say this is absolutely do
OMS cut out of this movie I just think
there's a lot of signs that point to
something some kind of subplot being
removed and I think it makes a lot of
sense if you look at all the other
evidence that's pointing in other
different directions that that uh that
missing puzzle piece is in the shape of
Victor Von Doom uh it just makes a lot
of sense to me that that might have been
cut and I I don't know if we can go as
far to say that Sasha baronco that like
the fact he's playing me Fisto is like a
cover Story released by Disney Disney
doesn't normally do that like play with
like The Hollywood Reporter and say yeah
yeah our sources just print that it's
Mephisto but if we end up being right on
that I think we deserve to be like hired
by Marvel Studios right out all right we
have a few more questions we want to
talk about from kind of forever thank
you to Brooklyn and for sponsoring this
episode the holidays are just around the
corner in Brooklyn and is here to make
holiday hosting so easy they've got
everything you need to outfit your guest
room grab a great gift with Brooklyn and
stoppable bundles you're literally all
set they've done all the work for you
with the combinations for bed bath or
both to save you time and money with
bundles your holiday hosting prep has
never been simpler their luxurious Home
Essentials feel as good as they look and
offer something for everyone whether
you're searching for accessories or
investing in Forever favorites that make
a House a Home Brooklyn is a sure bet
they are known for their award-winning
sheets but they also have an expanded
selection of Home fragrance bathroom
essentials and comfortable loungewear
don't forget about the rewards program
where with each purchase you earn points
perks and Insider info on all of
Brooklyn's exclusive member events and
promotions on top of all the coziness on
the horizon Brooklyn and is offering
something extra special for first-time
customers visit brooklinen.com today and
save 15 off your first purchase plus
free shipping that's
b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com for 15 off your
first purchase plus free shipping we
also want to thank Helix sleep for
sponsoring this episode while we dream
about Doom coming to the MCU we want to
do it with a comfortable mattress We
Trust Helix to give us those Doctor Doom
build dreams of the best mattresses in
the world I had a helix mattress as does
MT recently producer Zach producer John
also got Helix mattresses Helix sleep
has a quiz it takes just two minutes to
complete and matches your body type and
your sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you everybody unique and
Helix knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses matches is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot mattress is
great for spinal alignment to prevent
morning aches and pains even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers
producer John Tiffany Helix quiz and was
matched with the Helix dusk mattress
because he is a back sleeper that needed
a memory foam mattress to provide the
amount of support to keep him sleeping
through the night just go to Helix
sleep.com inside Marvel take their two
minute sleep quiz and they'll match you
to a customized mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life they
have a 10 year warranty and you get to
try it out for 100 nights risk-free
Helix is operating up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at Helix sleep.com inside
marble alright this is like the common
criticism a lot of people are bringing
up with wakanda forever I wanted to get
both of your opinions on this wood would
kind of forever have been better without
Val and would have been better without
reread
absolutely not
absolutely not okay
okay
so there's a couple things at new rock
stars that I am overly protected of like
I think some of us are about certain
things that we really enjoy in our lives
and mine is Riri Williams She-Hulk and
the boys but
Riri Williams is so perfect and I I hate
to be this person but like throwing her
into every predominantly black film that
the MCU will be handling out even the
ones that take place in predominantly
black neighborhoods whether Chicago New
York is a great idea because this person
creates inventions from nothing this
person isn't Rich isn't uh didn't go to
like didn't start off as like a prodigy
genius that went to like all the highest
schools no she makes stuff out of her
garage in Chicago so I think putting her
in wakanda Forever is like how I feel
about them running into MJ and Ned it's
written in the stars they go to MIT they
need to see each other you have to put
riwi in wakanda Forever not only to give
her another teammate because she does
have An Occurrence she does run in with
shuri and the wakandans and helps build
like Space Engineering for wakanda in
the comics so it's like yeah this is her
buddy this is her friend but this is
also another intelligent black girl that
knows what she's doing knows what she's
going through and can they can both
assist and bounce off each other so I
think rear Williams for the MCU best
introduction is through wakanda forever
I'm so glad it was wakanda forever
instead of like Spider-Man instead of
anything else I needed it to be wakanda
forever sorry that isn't that is fine
I agree with um because like like you
said like this movie was very much a
celebration of strong black women and
like Ruby Williams since she's like next
up on the Block after Iron Man it just
makes sense for wakanda forever to be
the movie to introduce
um and to introduce this character
because like at the beginning of the MCU
we didn't really have a lot of strong
black female characters
um to to attach to but like now with
this movie we have we have shuri we have
Riri we have Okoye we have yeah the
other midnight uh
I'm forgetting your name
is girlfriend
um like it just like it was just really
dope to to see this because you like
before we didn't really we didn't really
have this
um and so like it's I feel like this
means a lot for a lot of uh black
um female nerds out there that like just
really want characters and heroes to
attach to and so like I definitely feel
like Riri should have been this but Val
definitely didn't have to be in this but
I understand that you know this is just
the MCU laying down the seeds for what's
coming later so like I'm I'm cool with
it because like we are watching an MCU
movie it that was the MCU part was the
Val and Everett Ross part but it also
when I left the theater the second time
watching it I was like not in a mean way
but I was like out of every storyline
theirs was like the one lacking for me
with like me caring like the I it was a
big thing it was a big thing but I think
the biggest thing for me the takeaway
was that they were married at one point
and I was like I guess I didn't need to
hear that in this movie I could have
heard it anywhere and it would have been
fine it gave us more theories it gives
us more work it gives us more everything
to do but I also was like yeah I don't
it could have came later and I still
would have felt the same way because
they ended up breaking them out anyways
right right I mean uh yeah I think all
of this is coming from a place where we
genuinely love uh Julia Louis-Dreyfus
and anytime she's on screen I'm I'm like
Yay like I mean I just love uh her work
as an actor and Dominique Thorne I think
is incredible yeah I think these
criticisms about like riri's Ark in this
is nothing against the character I think
everyone is on the same page in terms of
like bringing this character in the MCU
introducing her in a cool way giving her
a lot of fun stuff to do and I think she
is a delight to watch in this movie I
just think structurally in this movie uh
she is kind of like forced into a plot
that the character does not need to be a
part of if the if the Thematic goal of
this movie is to use shuri to teach
audiences how to mourn uh how does RiRi
Williams serve that thematic goal and I
think overall they pull it off and pull
it off so well it just reminds me a lot
of when we watched uh Civil War right
like Peter Parker's introduction Civil
War is awesome is a lot of fun
um but his introduction to that movie
does distract from the Thematic conflict
of Civil War it's really just done to
introduce an exciting new character that
we all want to see in a movie that we're
all going to watch
um but like structurally structurally
you could totally tell a version of
wakanda forever in which it was
sure eats technology that she didn't
know that she was building and had some
kind of deal with the government and
then it's her fault that this uh
vibranium detector technology got in the
wrong hands that's where I think uh for
storytelling purposes I wouldn't be as
involved if it was just shuri I'd be
like okay this girl's mourning and on
top of that you guys somehow broke into
wakanda stole her technology and then
found vibranium that's why I think they
needed someone on the outskirts of
wakanda to be able to create an
invention that could find it and I also
think I mean yeah Ryan cooler didn't
have a lot of time to rewrite of a lot
of the stuff but I think it's like that
it it the only fault I'll give them is
like that's too close to America Chavez
and Multiverse of Madness where it's
like we're trying to hunt down this one
girl for doing something that she didn't
mean to do she does exists with it but I
was like you for a justification story
with line purposes it always gives you
that like it's always you hit that wall
which I like is of like yeah I
understand random more is coming from
but also this is a child scientist but
to them it's like no this is a scientist
and she create an invention that can
kill us all even if it she didn't mean
to so I'm like yeah I like that being
Riri and I like that for storytelling
but For The Grieving part of
Storytelling I don't think it does
contribute but for like storyline
purposes of climaxes I think it does but
that's that's also me because I ride or
die for that woman so
that's fine I mean what a character that
I think is still okay to die on the hill
of because she's incredible she's great
I love Riri I think that I don't know I
feel like riri's introduction into story
or inclusion of the story rather sort of
serves as the purpose of like showing
wakanda sort of like you know providing
a little bit of humility to wakanda a
little bit because wakanda is like we
got all the smartest people we've got
all the vibranium and then they learned
that like they don't have all the
smartest people because riri's out there
and though there's vibranium in the
ocean so it's just like oh [ __ ] maybe we
should really do what t'challa said and
learn more about our world because
um we're not as special as we thought we
were we we were pretty special but like
we're not not as special because like
now there are more crazier things happen
we have a rereads coming up we have
vibranium being a factor so I think that
um it but also speaking to the grief
part we do have that little small uh
part where we
um talks about her father and and losing
her Father which is a big part of her uh
her origin story in the comics
um as well and so like you know but we
also know that you know she likes to
like put herself in her work and like
distract herself into work
um to sort of like Get over that trauma
what's sort of like Tony Stark in a way
um in Iron Man 3 and so I think that
uh
having that conversation with Riri might
have like inspired
um uh uh shuri to go and make that herb
it's like you know what let me just
distract myself with my work I'm
stressed out Mama Dead everything going
bad
um water is dangerous uh time to make a
nerve these are all very good points
these are all very good points I I think
the people who are criticizing this I'm
not saying I'm one of them I just think
it's an interesting conversation so I
wanted to have it here um but I think
like uh the fact that she has to be Riri
Williams MIT student from Chicago and
there's certain story beats with her
origin story that they have to stick to
like you have to establish Peter Parker
as a kid from Queens you know like I was
thinking structurally if you know they
weren't if they weren't uh beholden to
those story beats you could have just
introduced three Williams as a uh as a
student in one of these wakanda Outreach
centers you know or wherever else and
then she is like working on an
internship project for them and then it
gets raided by the US government or the
French government or whoever it is and
then she did end up created it could
still be the same story beat it's just
the fact that we had to like divert them
movie and then go to MIT and we had to
watch her like tutoring other students
for for cash and had to follow her in
her dorm I thought it was all very
entertaining and fun it just like really
like in the First Act derailed the movie
from like tonally from what I think the
the central thematic goal of the movie
was I don't think overall it hurts I
think it just kind of like not
necessarily hurtful just not helpful
it's more so like which one would you
have rather wanted to see the like
Oakland campus or would you rather see
the MIT campus and I know that through
break room everyone was always fighting
whether or not she was at MIT it was
like always a fight we didn't care about
the like oh Outreach Center it was like
does she go to MIT or not is she not at
that campus because there's other
teachers and other alumni that came out
of MIT that this could all connect to so
and also we know that Ryan Cooper is a
super big comic book fan so honestly
he's looking at people like us and is
like I'll just give them more stuff to
work with you here you go
well I think we can all agree as much as
we love these actors they all they've
done such a good job casting it's we're
really just talking about story
structure and I think what I would
really love to see is like release these
movies as the best possible movie it
could be and then have like Disney plus
one-off specials to introduce these like
tie-in things leading up to it or on the
other side of it and then you could just
give the character the focus of these
things without distracting from the
story of overall and I would give that
note to all the movies like I think
definitely for Civil War I think uh
maybe the movie wouldn't have made as
many millions of dollars as it did
um uh Multiverse of Madness I think
America Chavez kind of has his damsel
syndrome throughout the movie that I
feel like Riri has in this movie I'm not
crazy about that because I feel like I
think they did a slightly better job of
it at least structurally with uh
Multiverse advantis but Riri I think is
a far more interesting character who I'm
excited to see in the future than I am
about America Chavez that's just me
personally let's move on to the question
of this sun underwater and I was on
slack this week being like what the hell
is no more talking about where he's like
I brought the sun to my people and we
see this blowing thing rise out of this
pyramid and I was just like what is that
like we just see like a glowing thing is
that just supposed to be like vibranium
Tech empty I know you had an interesting
take on this that I really loved oh yeah
no I I honestly believe that I was so
excited when I saw that vibranium um sun
because I was like wow they more
literally took a vibranium spear flew it
up to the sky and absorbed all that
solar radiation and then brought it down
to
um talocon to light up his people so
that is literally solar energy that's
that's quite literally the Sun and I
thought that was so like so smart I sort
of want to go into this in a future
video but like this is sort of a key
part to why Neymar is a mutant um
because we learned from eternals that uh
the sun solar energy
um this is from what I gleaned anyway
um it's responsible for evolution it's
responsible for the reason why you know
we see Crow absorbing all this radiation
this solar radiation that the eternals
absorbed in their body and he was slowly
solving when he did so so I feel like
the solar radiation is a key symbolic
piece for um Namor being a mutant in the
MCU and um we'll we'll probably learn
more about that in future films I really
loved how I use this piece of vibradium
to absorb the sun to just give light to
like a really dark and scary uh because
like that journey to talocon was super
cool very fine to nebo-esque but like my
God would I be uh pooping in my suits
because that is just darkness just
darkness like I was like freaking out I
was like I couldn't be me could not be
me Lord just what do you think he meant
by I brought the sun to my I I'm an
idiot and I literally think when he was
when she was when she mentioned like oh
it's vibranium I was like oh this is
just a vibranium Sun that he
he locked up and can just Expose and to
make look like daylight but once Mt did
say his theory I was like that sounds
badass and I love it it and I wanted to
stick to the comments but I do think
that's I'm like I do think it's just
made out of vibranium and I think like
the people there understand the
vibranium exist within like the soil or
inside the plants but I think it's like
he's the one that's taking it
repurposing it into bigger things and I
haven't seen him do any science any
metal bending any anything but I do
think he created this sun maybe it took
a long time and also science wise I
don't know a lot about water but I know
reflection and
[Music]
you know you don't wear Sun speed before
you get
that's very intelligent that I cannot
get into it's beyond our understanding
auntie I really love your theory I love
it it's so fun it's also just to be like
vibranium equals magic uh material right
like you actually had that whole thing
of like it will work the heart-shaped
herbal will work if it glows so maybe
there's like an inherent glow to it I
mean my theory is that like oh that's
true the these meteorites made a
vibrating were sent by the celestials so
maybe like this is like similar to the
celestial World Forge how it's just kind
of like uh it can produce light uh in in
dark spaces otherwise like this is the
same stuff that creates stars and other
like glowing celestial bodies and he was
able to create a microcosm version of it
underwater I think going off what you
said also an empty if you do a video
talk about it going off what you said
Remember the light up beads the C the
sea the C whatever she said that was
handling in the cave that also
illuminated
if he's using glow worms and
phosphorescent lights or phosphorescent
you know what I'm talking about water
yeah and it makes that yeah
I don't know science
I'm doing great you're doing great we
know what you're talking about
I I came from a peninsula so I know some
water terms but I think I think you've
seen those things if you use those items
in the water that naturally give off its
own light mixed in with vibranium he's
probably creating something that
illuminates as bright as the sun
underwater someone else do the math for
it but please I think that's I think
that works
when she said the glowing of the herb I
was like oh yeah absolutely 100 it's a
glow it's maybe it's not a light it's a
glow if that makes sense well speaking
of future videos I know Mt has like a
whole herb breakdown
nerves guys
I do talk about the the glowing energy
and and um yes okay it's gonna be it's
gonna be perfect because it's I'm so
excited good stuff we'll leave it there
for this episode of inside Marvel but
next week Mt and Jessica and I are
finally going to give our follow-up to
our October episode where we race The
Immortal space for Disney plus Series
this time we're gonna rank the seven MCU
baseball movies please that's right and
Jessica's gonna explain why eternals is
obviously the best of them
Jessica is a big eternals and jubilees
stand you heard it here first oh that is
adorable I'm gonna be at La Comic-Con
and I'm planning on dressing up as
Jubilee just to make everyone that loves
Jubilee mad because you guys all know I
don't like Jubilee so it's out of a bit
I'm gonna pay extra money to look so
good as Jubilee just to make all of you
man you got it because you secretly love
her I don't like her okay go keep going
close out this show I need to leave I
hate everybody here
well uh I'm very excited for next week
uh I think that might come out on
Thanksgiving day so we'll have like a
nice controversial thing to take away
from your fights at the family yeah
you can follow Jessica at Lulu
underscore Clements follow MTM
ascertainment follow me at eava
subscribe to inside Marvel wherever you
get your podcast thanks for watching and
we'll see you next week bye everybody
bye
thank you
foreign